[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم الخارجيه القطريه تعلن
نجاح وسطه قطريه في التوصل لاتفاق بين
اسرائيل وحماس لادخال مساعدات للمدنيين في
غزه مقابل ايصال ادويه للمحتجزين في
القطاع مكتب نتنياهو يؤكد ان ايصال
الادويه للمختطفين سيبدا اليوم الاربعاء
والبيت الابيض يقول ان مستشار الامن
القومي ناقش مع رئيس الوزراء القطري جهود
اطلاق سراح جميع الرهائن المتبقين لدى
حماس تجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في
رابط التعليق الاول على خلفيه قصف طهران
لاراضي باكستانيه وزاره الخارجيه
الباكستانيه تستدعي سفيرها في ايران
والمحدثه باسم خارجيه اسلام بات تقول ان
طهران تتحمل تبعات وعواقب ما قامت به
ووزير الخارجيه الايراني يؤكد ان بلاده
استهدفت ما وصفها بمجموعه ارهابيه ويقول
نحترم سياده ووحده اراضي باكستان لكننا لن
نقبل بان يهدد امننا القومي هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه تقول ان 17 مدنيا اصيبوا بقصف
روسي بصاروخين من طراز اس 300 على مدينه
خاركيف وتعلن عن اسقاط 19 طائره من اصل 20
اطلقها الجيش الروسي على جنوب اوكرانيا
هواتف ايفون من شركه ابل تتفوق على هواتف
شركه سامسونج لتصبح سلسله الهواتف الذكيه
الاكثر مبيعا خلال عام
2022 بتسجيل اكثر من 230 مليون شحنه وبهذا
تخسر الشركه الكوريه سامسونج المركز الاول
للمره الاولى منذ 13 عاما الى
اللقاء
ه